yeah well I think it's it's a lot it's I
mean that opioid epidemic thing you know
like I remember watching that show what
was that show that I really liked yeah
dopesick you see dopesick no man I don't
know if I could handle it but I I live
in a place with a lot of that so I see
it well it's about the F it's about
Michael Keaton is in it right I think
that's him he used to be Batman but now
I guess he's selling drugs right which
is a perfect example oh it's it's about
puru Pharma it's a perfect example of
our country even Batman is [__]
selling pills you now well the company
that got the country got Rural America
hooked on opioids got away with it I
mean they nobody went to jail yeah the
Sackler family they're still they're
still rich and like really they didn't
go to jail that's what this this ruined
my this ruin
this I think about this every single day
I hate the Sackler family I hate this
whole thing that happened it's
unbelievable they got away with it how
do you do that well these people this
country let they they let a our FDA let
the these people down but no one was
punished not one person was punished
yeah I know and you see people go to
jail I mean this not even a political
point it's true and both s you know
voters for both parties go to jail for
very small things very small things yeah
and yet you like poison the entire
country you wreck an entire generation
of kids and you're still a billionaire
tell me how that works I don't know if I
ever saw that guy on the street I would
[__] saw his face off how would you
saw his face off I'd figure it out do
you do you bring us do you have a saw
with you I just turned into a saw that's
how much I hate that
guy you know I mean it's just
unbelievable how many people I got
killed in no care concern no and then
the way that they lobbied our own FDA
people they took them off of the job and
paid them more to work for them to help
them beat the laws yeah sorry man I
didn't mean to bring that up no no no
but I mean next time they tell me I have
to take some Pharma product I'm probably
going to pass I'm just saying yeah I'm
probably gonna pass I don't trust you
anymore sorry well I miss the days you
could get some [__] good pills too I
mean there's part of that in this you
know when a dude could give you a couple
stack or twos you know you'd hold up the
wall over there in uh in hoken for an
hour you know I think those days are are
are over you got to go to fenel I just
don't want to do it no I don't think you
should well I'll overdose man I'm so I'm
sober like 18 months I would overdose
easy You're Sober 18 months one of the
reasons I don't do cocaine anymore is
because they [__] ruined it why with
the fenel used to be his baby LAX
yeah but I'd rather [__] than die you
know I agree with that completely you
know I'd rather get off the toilet and
be like oh that was hectic than be like
you know laying there just like God wish
I could [__] but I got to go to heaven
and that and that by the way is a
guess
okay